some breaking news to bring you now and
it has been announced in the last few
moments we understand that the former
chancellor of the exchequer rishi sunak
has declared that he also is throwing
his hat in the ring to be the next prime
minister he's put it there on his
twitter feed i'm standing to be the next
leader of the conservative party and
your prime minister well we can bring in
our chief political correspondent john
craig um
not
entirely a surprise is it but there it
is he's standing
yes he is has confirmed he's standing i
must admit it always look likely on the
the dramatic events of well have been
plenty of dramatic events this week but
on tuesday evening at six o'clock or
thereabouts when uh the prime minister
was giving an interview uh saying sorry
for the chris pincher affair and saying
he'd made mistakes and so on you'll
remember first we had
sajid javid quit and then a few minutes
later rishi sunak quit now those two are
very close
and
at the time it did appear that rishi
sunak would be quitting to prepare for a
leadership bid or a leadership challenge
well now we have confirmation uh rishi
sunak who is the
mp for richmond up in north yorkshire he
succeeded william hague there
when william hague left the house of
commons safe tory seat he's known as the
maharaja of the dales up there in
yorkshire fabulously wealthy now a few
months ago he was the darling of the
tory faithful and he looked like the
odds-on favorite to replace boris
johnson then came a series of rows about
his non-dom status his wife's tax
affairs and his wife's wealth
the question is has he been damaged by
that another question perhaps is will
his friend sajid javid uh support him or
decide to run himself it's possible
sajid javid maita
with perhaps the promise of returning to
the job of chancellor which he did very
briefly just on the statement we've just
had from rishi sunak incidentally he's
also um
he uh he's also uh produced a video a
campaign video of i think two or three
minutes uh which i haven't seen yet but
i'm told he has produced a video um
let's just study what he's saying uh
he's talking about restoring trust
rebuild the economy and reunite the
country
ready for rishi is his slogan
and you'll remember in his resignation
letter
on tuesday evening he did uh uh talk
about uh uh the damage that doris
johnson had done to uh trust in politics
and so on there was uh barely concealed
anger from boris johnson and his
supporters on tuesday evening because
unlike sajid javid who went to see the
prime minister
and out of courtesy informed him what he
was planning to do quit the cabinet the
first at inside number 10 they knew
about rishi sunak quitting was when they
saw his announcement which also came on
twitter
his resignation on tuesday was followed
by some pretty savage briefing against
him
by number 10 insiders and indeed the
prime minister said at a meeting with
conservative mps that evening
that perhaps now we'll be able to cut
taxes and of course rishi sunak's been
succeeded by nadeem zahawi who we expect
probably to be a candidate for the
leadership as well but what is becoming
clear
now is that as well as some of the
perhaps less senior candidates who've
thrown their hat in the ring already for
example some of the back benchers who
are talking about it like steve baker
swallow swallow sweller bravo man the
attorney general looks like the big
beasts in the tory jungle if i can use
that hackneyed old cliche are ready to
enter the contest because we have now
the chancellor of the exchequer as was
until tuesday and we are expecting a
declaration fairly soon from ben wallace
the defense secretary
who
is reported
to be poised to enter the race as well
he said he's consulting his family about
whether to run and the other senior
conservative cabinet minister we are
expecting to enter the race shortly is
liz trust the foreign secretary who has
been in indonesia for most of the week
when all the dramatic events have been
unfolding here at westminster she's due
back this evening so she may break her
silence as for rishi sunak well he is
ready to go he's know that got a team of
backers uh john sorry to interrupt you i
just need to let you know that hot on
the heels of that declaration of his
candidacy there for prime minister is
mark harper backing him
right well mark harper of course is a
former chief whip
former minister of the home office under
theresa may big critic of boris johnson
uh that is uh a fairly senior backer uh
for uh mr sunak i was just going on to
talk about other candidates declaring uh
we believe that uh a a declaration from
uh ben wallace is fairly imminent also
liz truss that uh
i thought for a second you were going to
say that uh that sadie javed was saying
he was going to back him that would be
highly significant because many mps
would regard the uh sunak uh javid
combination is a fairly attractive one
it has to be said though that there are
those who say conservative mps who say
that rishi soon acts uh appeal to uh
conservative mps and indeed members is
not what it was because of the non-dom
rao um
and that uh he's been damaged by this he
that he didn't handle it very well and
he was shown to be not particularly
robust or resilient under fire
so
um has he recovered from that or has he
been badly damaged by that however
mr sunak is uh poised to run real his
relations with the pm her the current pm
have deteriorated in recent months
clashes over economic policy the pm
wants to spend and cut taxes the
chancellor as was uh wants to
get the public finances in order not
borrow our way out of trouble and also
if you remember around about the time it
was around about april i think it was
when boris johnson said at prime
minister's questions uh talking about um
about um
sakir stama failing to prosecute jimmy
savile
rishi sunak very pointedly said i would
not have used that remark so relations
between boris johnson and rishi sunak
have been bad leading to his resignation
now mr sunak who is sitting there
addressing some workers on one of his
many visits uh has declared that he is
going to run he will be one of the front
runners probably not the front runner we
understand as well john angela
richardson mp has also tweeted her
support for the former chancellor as
well and we've been showing our viewers
on the screen i don't know if you've
seen it a very slickly edited uh pitch
video from rishi sunax suggests to me
that he hasn't made the decision to run
and the spur of the moment he's had this
in in the works for some time
looks like it doesn't it i mean it was
also pointed out that when he put in his
resignation letter uh on tuesday uh the
date um july the fifth the number five
was written whereas the rest of the
letter was typed no i'm sure he's been
plotting this for a long time some i was
about to say actually son cynics are
saying at least will he won't need any
millionaire donors to his campaign
because of course he's a millionaire and
his what family is in their own right he
will have enormous financial backing
he'll have some a slick media operation
we've already seen brand rishi uh uh
the way it's been operating
over recent months since he's been
chancellor uh angela richardson she is
the mp for guilford i think i'm right in
saying she was one of the ones who quit
as a parliamentary private secretary i
believe that's the video you're showing
there now there looks that looks like
pictures of when he was a little boy yes
me it says there um he will have plenty
of backers um he may well have some
interesting backers in uh what we used
to call fleet street for example he is
uh very friendly with james forsyth the
times columnist i think i'm right in
saying that mr sunak was his best man at
uh mr forsythe's wedding to allegra
stratton who of course you remember was
the downing street spokesperson who had
who quit in tears
over the mock news conference in the
downing street media suite but clearly
of the major front runners rishi sunak i
think it's fair to say
all due respect to the likes of tom
tougenhart who's never been a minister
and so
sowella bravaman who is uh less
well-known the attorney general um
rishi sunak is going to be
one of the leading contenders in this
race and uh he's gone early uh to get
some momentum uh no doubt uh but uh the
things we need to look out for in the
next few hours and days probably hours
is
to hear from ben wallace and liz truss
they're the ones that we are still
waiting to hear from uh whether that we
expect them to run we probably now will
expect to hear from them within hours
now that rishi sunak has set the
leadership contest alight uh by
announcing in a very slick professional
way that he is a candidate for prime
minister